dozens of worshippers are feared dead
after gunmen opened fire to church in
nigeria the attackers targeted the
catholic church in oahu in ondo state in
the southwest the dead include children
local media are reporting that a gunman
detonated explosives and shot
indiscriminately at their congregation
the church was busy for pentecost sunday
nigeria's military is battling a
jihadist insurgency but attacks are rare
in the ondo region
i'm now joined by dw correspondent amaka
okoye in lagos amaka
what more can you tell us about the
attack
andy i think today is one of those days
that you just wake up to hear one of
those news that of course nobody expects
to hear as you did mention there yes
unidentified gunman which is now almost
popular saying now sadly in nigeria
stunned that catholic church in our
today and then you know many people have
been killed over 50 as we do know
including children as you did mentioned
there yes what we what we heard is that
they did detonate some explosive to
scare the people but from the images
coming out there it's clearly people who
were shot at and targeted at a close
range and we've seen we've heard also
information that a lot of them have been
hospitalized those who are still alive
they're asking for blood donation you
know to see what more can be done to
save them and if you look again at the
images from what we've seen that place
is close to the palace we don't know if
that has any connection but that's the
kind of place that you suppose you would
say it's supposed to be a safe place but
unfortunately this has happened showing
how you know insecure the country is
especially like you did mention on those
states one of those that has been
relatively peaceful but today the story
has changed and there are scores of
people who the numbers we can't
ascertain yet that have been killed and
others seriously injured as we speak now
in hospital
really it is as you've seen because most
of the previous attacks have been taking
place in the northwest uh so this is a
bit of an
abnormality if i can say might this
signal disturbing widening of the
violence
i mean what this clearly points to is
the fact that i mean no part of the
country is safe uh in the past would say
well some of these sort of killings they
are very common in the north
unfortunately that we have to say that
you know or recently we also saw an
increase in you know killings and
attacks by unidentified gunmen but today
i i think that narrative has changed and
that's quite worrying uh when if you
listen to the the statement from the
state uh the governor he did mention
that uh this is not the sort of things
that they have seen and he called it
some satanic or a devilish attack uh but
the problem is that insecurity is
increasing by the day and nowhere is
safe and no place is exempt from this
and that's what this clearly suggests
and even as the run-up into election
season it is quite worrying to see these
sort of attacks on broad daylight you
know targeting people soft churches
being soft targets and places like that
it's quite worrying
i'm making
in lagos thank you